This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the 1940s there were, as there are today, a lot of great art and design schools in New York City, Pratt, Cooper Union, Parsons. And there were then, as there are today, a lot of young talented artists and designers that those schools would go on to have great careers. But in the 1940s there was something else that some of those artists and designers had
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。在上世纪 40 年代，就像今天一样，纽约市有很多优秀的艺术和设计学校：普拉特（Pratt）、库珀联盟（Cooper Union）、帕森斯（Parsons）。当时和现在一样，这些学校培养了许多才华横溢的年轻艺术家和设计师，他们后来都迎来了伟大的职业生涯。但在 40 年代，其中一些艺术家和设计师还有
to do first. That's our own Katie Mingle. There was a war going on, World War II, and the Army needed artists because, well, they had kind of a crazy idea. And it was a crazy idea that came out of one of the most conservative organizations you can imagine, the United States Army. That's Rick Byer, more about Rick in a minute. And it had to go up the line to high-ranking generals up as high as Eisenhower himself
另一项任务必须先完成。这是我们节目的凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。当时正爆发着第二次世界大战，军队需要艺术家，因为，嗯，他们有个挺疯狂的想法。这个疯狂的想法出自你能想象到的最保守的机构之一——美国陆军。这位是里克·拜尔（Rick Byer），稍后会介绍更多关于他的信息。这个想法必须层层上报到高级将领，甚至直达艾森豪威尔本人
to get approval. The crazy idea was this. The United States Army would design a deception unit, a unit that would appear to the enemy to be a large armor division. Thousands of soldiers, tanks, trucks, guns, only this unit would actually be equipped with fake tanks, fake trucks, fake guns, and manned by just a handful of soldiers. And it really is something unusual. Rick Byer has a forthcoming book about all of this and also made a film about it called The Ghost Army.
才能获得批准。这个疯狂的想法是这样的：美军将设计一个欺骗部队，一个在敌人看来像是一个大型装甲师的部队。数千名士兵、坦克、卡车、大炮，只不过这支部队实际上装备的是假坦克、假卡车、假大炮，并且只由少数士兵操作。这确实是一件很不寻常的事。里克·拜尔即将出版一本关于这一切的书，还拍了一部同名纪录片《幽灵军队》（The Ghost Army）。
People say to me, well, did the Germans have something like this? Did the Japanese have something like this? And what I've said is, the Germans and Japanese did deceptions, but I haven't found anybody ever who had a unit quite like this one. D-Day, June 6, 1944, marked the start of the most critical period of War II. The Allies landed on the beaches of Normandy and began to liberate France from the Germans who had occupied it for four years at that point. They were ultimately marching toward Berlin. And the success of the
人们对我说，嗯，德国人有类似的东西吗？日本人有类似的东西吗？我的回答是，德国人和日本人确实搞过欺骗，但我从未发现任何人拥有过像这样独特的部队。D日，即 1944 年 6 月 6 日，标志着第二次世界大战中最关键时期的开始。盟军在诺曼底海滩登陆，开始将法国从被占领了四年的德国人手中解放出来。他们的最终目标是向柏林挺进。而
Normandy landings on Dede was due in part to deception. Using a variety of techniques, the Allies tricked the Germans into thinking the invasion would happen at a different time and place. But a couple of US Armymen, Ralph Ingersoll and Billy Harris wanted to take deception to a whole new level. They wanted to create a mobile deception unit. And we're going to put that on the battlefield and give that to the generals to use for whatever set of circumstances come up. So what were the circumstances in which a unit like this would be needed? Well, let's say American forces are guarding a border, but there's a hole in one spot. And if the Germans
诺曼底登陆在 D 日的成功，部分要归功于欺骗战术。盟军通过各种技术，欺骗德国人，让他们以为入侵会在不同的时间和地点发生。但两名美国陆军军人拉尔夫·英格索尔（Ralph Ingersoll）和比利·哈里斯（Billy Harris）希望将欺骗战术提升到一个全新的水平。他们想要创建一支机动欺骗部队。我们要把它投入战场，交给将领们，在任何突发情况下使用。那么，在什么情况下需要这样一支部队呢？嗯，假设美军正在守卫一条边境线，但某个地方出现了一个缺口。如果德国人
realize there's an unguarded spot, they could use it to break the line. But the Americans don't have any troops to fill that hole. Sometimes they can't send the real troops because the real troops are needed someplace else. And sometimes they can't send them because they just don't have enough or they can't get them there in time. That's where the ghost army came in. This top secret unit was officially called the 23rd Headquarters Special Troops
意识到有一个无人守卫的缺口，他们就可以利用它来突破防线。但美军没有任何军队来填补这个缺口。有时他们无法调动真正的军队，因为真部队在其他地方有急用；有时他们无法调动，是因为人数根本不够，或者无法及时赶到。这就是幽灵军队派上用场的时候。这支最高机密的部队官方名称叫作“陆军第 23 总部特别部队”
and nicknamed the ghost army after the war. The so-called ghost army would impersonate a larger armored division. Might be the Six Armored Division or some other one, it changed. But a division that was made up of, say, 15 or 20,000 soldiers. When they, the Ghost Army, were actually only about a thousand men. You want to make it seem like something is there that isn't there. And if you want people to do that, you're going to want artists. The army was interested in recruiting people with art, with an art background.
战后被称为“幽灵军队”。所谓的幽灵军队将扮演一个大型装甲师。可能是第六装甲师或其他什么部队，番号经常变动。但那是一个由比如说 1.5 万或 2 万名士兵组成的师。而他们——幽灵军队，实际上只有大约一千人。你想让人觉得那里有什么东西，但实际上并没有。如果你想让人们做到这一点，你就会需要艺术家。军队对招募具有艺术背景的人很感兴趣。
We were going to do installations of sorts. That's Jack Macy. I'm Jack Macy during World War II. I served in the Ghost Army. Before the Army, Jack was just a kid in high school, a pretty famous high school in New York City called the High School of Music and Art. It's now called LaGuardia High School.
我们要搞各种装置艺术。那是杰克·马西（Jack Macy）。我是杰克·马西，在二战期间，我在幽灵军队服役。参军前，杰克只是纽约市一所高中里普通的孩子，那是一所相当有名的高中，叫做音乐与艺术高中（High School of Music and Art）。现在它叫拉瓜迪亚高中（LaGuardia High School）。
I was an art major. So young Jack is shipped off to Europe to join the camouflage unit, where he discovers that a lot of the other guys in his unit are also artists. A good 50% will say. And one of the things all of those artists had been working on was designing fake tanks and trucks. By the time Jack got to Europe, they'd done all their R&D and decided rubber was the
我是个艺术专业学生。于是年轻的杰克被运送到欧洲加入伪装部队，在那里他发现他所在的部队里也有很多其他艺术家。可以说足足有 50%。所有这些艺术家一直在做的事情之一，就是设计假坦克和假卡车。等杰克到达欧洲时，他们已经完成了所有的研发工作，并决定橡胶是
best material to use. And so that's when I discovered my first inflatable tank. Inflatable rubber tanks were a crucial part of the visual deception unit. You could inflate one to see something rise like a souffle and about a half hour from nothing to a full tank was rather quite interesting, okay? But the visual deception unit had more than just tanks.
使用的最佳材料。也就是在那时，我发现了我的第一个充气坦克。充气橡胶坦克是视觉欺骗部队的关键部分。你可以给它充气，看着它像舒芙蕾一样膨胀起来，从一无所有到一个完整的坦克大概需要半个小时，这相当有趣，对吧？但视觉欺骗部队拥有的可不止是坦克。
It's tanks and trucks and artillery and jeeps and all sorts of vehicles, virtually every kind of vehicle the Army has, the ghost Army had inflatable versions of. Basically anything to make themselves appear to be the full-sized, armored division that they were pretending to be. This stuff was all meant to be believable from a distance for planes flying overhead or maybe people looking through binoculars. And at a distance, the inflatables were super realistic, but you had to be careful about certain details.
坦克、卡车、火炮、吉普车和各种车辆，军队拥有的几乎每一种车辆，幽灵军队都有充气版本。基本上，只要能让自己看起来像是他们所假装的那支满编制的装甲师就行。这些东西都要做到从远处看能够以假乱真，无论是从头顶飞过的飞机，还是用望远镜观察的人。在一定距离外，这些充气模型超级逼真，但你必须注意某些细节。
Sometimes the barrels of the know, of the tanks, were not that inflated and they sagged. Well, of course, that was a mess. Flacid gun barrels, never a good thing, but there were other details to consider. A real tank weighs 40 tons, and when it drives across the field, it leaves a set of tank tracks that are really obvious to aerial reconnaissance. So the deception unit would actually use a bulldozer to make fake tracks around the fake tanks. But there was one cardinal rule, Jack says, about working with inflatables.
有时，你知道的，坦克的炮管没有完全充气，导致它们下垂了。好吧，当然，那可就糟了。软绵绵的炮管，这可绝不是什么好事，但还有其他细节需要考虑。真正的坦克重达 40 吨，当它驶过田野时，会留下非常明显的履带痕迹，空中侦察一眼就能看出来。因此，欺骗部队实际上会用推土机在假坦克周围制造假履带痕迹。但杰克说，使用充气模型有一条核心规则。
Never under any circumstances were you ever to carry an inflatable across the road. Obviously, two dudes carrying a 40-ton tank would look wrong. You weren't supposed to casually pick up and move an inflatable vehicle in a place where you could be seen. When the artist's soldiers weren't busy with their dummy tanks, Jack says they did what artists do. Spent their time sketching local people, local architecture, churches, all through Normandy, across France, and into Germany.
在任何情况下，都绝对不能扛着充气模型过马路。很明显，两个家伙抬着一辆 40 吨重的坦克看起来就不对劲。你不能在一个会被人看到的地方随随便便地把充气车辆捡起来搬走。杰克说，当艺术家士兵们不忙着处理他们的假坦克时，他们就会做艺术家该做的事。把时间花在素描当地人、当地建筑、教堂上，一路上穿过诺曼底、整个法国，一直到德国。
During their travels through Europe, when they weren't sketching local architecture, the ghost army was often acting. And they call it special effects, and I call it play acting, because that's really what it was. And the idea was first to go into town and sit down at a cafe, so that anybody watching us...
在他们穿梭于欧洲的旅途中，当不画当地建筑时，幽灵军队经常在演戏。他们称之为特效，而我称之为过家家，因为这确实就是那么回事。当时的想法是先去镇上，在咖啡馆里坐下，好让任何看着我们的人……
Remember, the Germans had occupied France for four years at this point. So yeah, there were spies everywhere. We wanted them to think that not only did we have actual tanks, which of course we didn't, but that we actually were members of the Second Alma Division, which in fact rewarned. They stenciled fake unit numbers on their trucks, they made fake patches to put on their sleeves. Sometimes they seem to be having a little too much fun with this part of the job. Like the time they stole a bunch of cases of expensive cognac from a tavern
记住，此时德国人已经占领法国四年了。所以，是的，到处都是间谍。我们希望他们不仅认为我们有真正的坦克——当然我们并没有，而且认为我们确实是第二装甲师的成员——事实上我们并不是。他们在卡车上喷涂假的部队番号，制作假的臂章戴在袖子上。有时他们似乎在这部分工作里玩得有点太嗨了。比如有一次他们从一家酒馆偷走了一箱箱昂贵的干邑白兰地
just to piss off the tavern owner, and they knew to be a German collaborator. They are hoping that he is then going to be so angry at them that he's going to go to the Germans and tell them, well not only do I know that the Sixth Armored Division is here, but their general was at my tavern today. The whole point of the Ghost Army was to make sure their presence was known. The Ghost Army needed to be seen and heard and perceived by the Germans as being real. On turntable 1 goes the recording of truck moving in, which brings us to the deception unit that I probably would have been drafted into, sonic deception. So they would record the sounds of tanks going down roads
纯粹是为了气气酒馆老板，而他们知道这人是个德国合作者。他们希望这家伙会因此气急败坏，跑去找德国人告状，不仅说他知道第六装甲师在这里，还说他们的将军今天在他的酒馆里。幽灵军队的核心意义在于确保他们的存在被察觉。幽灵军队需要被德国人看到、听到，并被认为真实存在。1 号唱盘上播放着卡车驶入的录音，这就把我们带到了我差点被征召进去的欺骗部队——声音欺骗。所以他们会录下坦克在路上行驶的声音
or the sounds of trucks of men reaching a certain point and all the men jumping out. And then be able to play them back in such a way as to make the enemy think that those things are really happening. This was all so new and strange that the army made a top secret film which explained how sound could be used to deceive the enemy.
或者卡车运载人员到达某地后所有人跳下车的声音。然后以某种方式将其播放出来，让敌人以为这些事情正在发生。这一切是如此新奇和陌生，以至于军队拍摄了一部绝密电影，解释了如何利用声音来欺骗敌人。
In it, actors, badly portray a group of German officers Army made a top secret film which explained how sound could be used to deceive the enemy. In it, actors, badly portray a group of German officers who are the midst of being punked by the Sonic deception unit. Did you say tanks? What are these nonsense about tanks? Our OP here reports definite sounds of tanks moving into assembly about there. The movie goes on to explain that the Germans in that scene were fooled. A summit company had convinced them that an armored division undercover of darkness had
影片中，演员们拙劣地扮演了一群德国军官……（注：原文此处有音频回放/重复）军队拍摄了一部绝密电影，解释了如何利用声音来欺骗敌人。影片中，演员们拙劣地扮演了一群德国军官，他们正被声音欺骗部队恶作剧。你刚才说坦克？这些关于坦克的胡言乱语是怎么回事？我们的前沿观察哨报告有明确的声音表明坦克正在集结到那个位置附近。电影接着解释说，那一幕中的德国人被骗了。某某连队让他们相信，夜色掩护下的一个装甲师已经
moved along the river across from them. The enemy committed his tank destroyers and reserves to this bridge head up here. They moved into position and waited, and they waited. And we crossed down here where they weren't. The film goes into great detail about the process of recording and playing back sounds. The best loudspeakers for the military requirements have been developed.
沿着他们对面的河流移动了。敌人将坦克歼击车和预备队投入到了这里的这个桥头堡。他们进入阵位等待着，等待着……而我们却从他们不在的下游渡过了河。这部电影详细介绍了录音和播放声音的过程。适合军事需求的最佳扬声器已经研制成功。
The speakers could project sound as far as 15 miles, and there was a huge library of sounds to choose from. For example, engines make different sounds depending on the terrain, and they had all of those different kinds of sounds. At the little hill, this one projected the sound of tanks going up. This one projected tanks going down. They would look at what they're trying to simulate, what are we trying to make people think is happening, and then they would take all the appropriate sounds and mix them together to create a sonic story.
这些扬声器可以将声音传送到远达 15 英里之外，而且有一个巨大的音效库可供选择。例如，发动机根据地形会发出不同的声音，他们拥有所有这些不同种类的声音。在小山丘上，这个装置播放的是坦克上坡的声音；那个播放的是坦克下坡的声音。他们会研究他们试图模拟什么，我们想让人们以为正在发生什么，然后他们会把所有相关的声音混合在一起，创作出一个声音故事。
People who heard this say that it was unbelievably eerie, that it was so realistic that you started seeing vehicles that weren't there. The third component of the Ghost Army were the radio operators. It was well known that the Germans listened in on radio communications of allied troops, so if the Ghost Army was trying to impersonate a real armored division, they'd have to send the right kinds of transmissions. They bring in trained radio operators from all sorts of other units to have the very best
听到这些的人说，这简直诡异得难以置信，它是如此逼真，以至于你开始看到那些根本不存在的车辆。幽灵军队的第三个组成部分是无线电操作员。众所周知，德国人一直在窃听盟军部队的无线电通信，因此，如果幽灵军队试图冒充一个真正的装甲师，他们就必须发送正确类型的电报。他们从各种其他部队调来受过训练的无线电操作员，以确保拥有最优秀的操作员
operators to be part of the radio deception unit. All of the units paid incredible attention to detail, but the radio operators had to be part of the radio deception unit. All of the units paid incredible attention to detail, but the radio operators had to be perfect mimics. They had to learn the exact keystrokes of an individual Morse code operator in the unit they were impersonating. The way a radio operator in the fourth armored division always starts his messages with four dots, you know,
来加入无线电欺骗部队。所有部队都对细节给予了难以置信的关注，但无线电操作员必须成为完美的模仿者。他们必须学会他们所冒充的部队中某个摩斯密码操作员的精确击键习惯。比如第四装甲师的一个无线电操作员总是在他的消息开头打四个点，你知道的，
da da da da, because that's just what they do. And if you don't do that, the German intercept person listening is going to think, well, wait a minute, is that really from the fourth armored division? So you have three different units, visual, sonic, and radio, and they're operating separately, but they're all organized by the same people, so they're very carefully working on different components of the same plan. The three separate units might only be vaguely aware of what one another were up to, and everything was kept completely secret from the rest of the military. If the fact of their mere existence ever leaked to the Germans,
哒哒哒哒，因为他们就是这么干的。如果你不这样做，正在监听的德国截听人员就会想：等等，这真的是来自第四装甲师的吗？所以你有三个不同的部队：视觉、声音和无线电，它们独立运作，但都是由同一批人组织起来的，因此它们非常仔细地在同一个计划的不同部分协同工作。这三个独立的部队可能只隐约知道彼此在做什么，而且对军队的其他部分完全保密。如果他们存在的事实哪怕有一点泄露给德国人，
the whole deception, as well as the safety of the Ghost Army could be compromised. The Ghost Army carried out 21 different deception missions between June 1944 and March 1945. Pretty much the entire time the US Army was operating in Europe. Rick says one of their most important missions was Operation Bedembourg, which took place near the border between France and Germany. So picture this. There's a river near the German border, the Mozel River. In German troops from one side and American troops from the other, they're part of a front
整个欺骗计划以及幽灵军队的安全都将受到威胁。从 1944 年 6 月到 1945 年 3 月，幽灵军队执行了 21 次不同的欺骗任务。几乎涵盖了美军在欧洲作战的整个时期。里克说，他们最重要的任务之一是贝登堡行动（Operation Viersen/Bedembourg），该行动发生在法德边境附近。想象一下这个场景：
that's hundreds of miles long. And then General George Patton realizes that there is a 75 mile gap in his line, an unguarded 75 miles that the Germans could use to break across the border if they knew about it. So they bring in the ghost army. So they arrived in about middle of the night. It's in September 44. And they're using all three units, the visual unit with the inflatable tanks, the radio guys, but especially the sonic deception unit. Because most of the Germans are on the other side
德军边境附近有一条河，莫泽尔河（Moselle River）。德国军队在河的一侧，美国军队在另一侧，他们是一条长达数百英里的前线的一部分。然后乔治·巴顿（George Patton）将军意识到他的防线出现了一个 75 英里宽的缺口，一个无人防守的 75 英里，如果德国人知道的话，完全可以利用它突破边境。于是他们把幽灵军队调了过来。他们大约在半夜到达。那是 44 年 9 月。
of the Mozel River. They're within earshot, in other words. And so it's a great opportunity to use sound, to build it up and make it seem like so many tanks are moving in and so many tanks are moving in and so many troops are moving in. The deception goes on for seven days. Seven days is a long time to fool anybody.
他们使用了所有三个部队：带有充气坦克的视觉部队、无线电人员，尤其是声音欺骗部队。因为大多数德国人都在莫泽尔河的另一边，换句话说，他们就在听力范围之内。所以这是一个绝佳的机会，利用声音大做文章，营造出许许多多坦克开进来、许许多多部队开进来的假象。欺骗行动持续了七天。七天对于欺骗任何人来说都是一段很长的时间。
The ghost army soldiers are getting nervous. They've never done a deception for this long before. And even General Patton is nervous. He wrote a letter to his wife and he says, One bad spot in my line, but I don't think the Huns know about it yet. We're holding on to it by the grace of God. We'll have it plugged by tomorrow. And the next day, the 83rd division moves in and takes over for the Ghost Army.
幽灵军队的士兵们开始紧张起来。他们以前从未进行过这么长时间的欺骗。就连巴顿将军也很紧张。他给妻子写信说：“我的防线有一个薄弱点，但我认为德国佬（Huns）还不知道。我们靠着上帝的恩典勉强守住。明天就能把它堵上。”第二天，第 83 师开进来接管了幽灵军队的防务。
And the Germans never caught on to the Ghost Army during that operation or any other. Over the course of the war, the Ghost Army lost three soldiers and had several dozen wounded. But overall, it was one of the safer assignments of War War II. Being in the camouflage unit, I always felt I was kind of lucky.
在这次行动以及其他任何行动中，德国人都从未识破幽灵军队。在整个战争期间，幽灵军队阵亡了三名士兵，数十人受伤。但总体而言，这是二战中最安全的任务之一。“在伪装部队里，我总是觉得自己挺幸运的。”
That's Jack Macy again. The camouflage unit was just another name for the visual deception unit. Because I had friends, you know, who were in the infantry, several were killed, several were wounded. But being assigned to the camouflage corps kept me away from the front lines. It's true that the ghost army suffered far fewer casualties than other units. That's partly because they were really good at their jobs. If their deception was ever uncovered by the Germans. It would be catastrophic for the men in the ghost army.
这是杰克·马西的话。伪装部队只是视觉欺骗部队的另一个名字。“因为我知道有些朋友在步兵连，好几个战死，好几个受伤。但被分配到伪装部队让我远离了前线。”诚然，幽灵军队的伤亡人数远少于其他部队。这部分是因为他们非常擅长自己的工作。如果他们的伪装被德国人识破，
They're operating without any heavy weapons. They don't have any real tanks. They don't have any real artillery. So they're kind of putting on this show of force in a very vulnerable place. Still, Jack remembers the army extremely fondly. He got to see Paris. To see Paris, the great cafes and the bistros
对于幽灵军队的人来说将是灾难性的。他们在没有任何重武器的情况下作战。他们没有任何真正的坦克，没有任何真正的火炮。所以他们有点像在一个非常脆弱的地方上演这场武力秀。尽管如此，杰克对军队的感情依然极其深厚。他得以去巴黎。
was a completely fabulous experience for me. After Jack Macy left the ghost army, he went to Yale. School of Art and Architecture, G.I. Bill of Rights. Thank God. After Yale, he went on to design some amazing things. He designed the kitchen used in the American National Exhibition in Moscow in 1959, with a famous debate between Nixon and Khrushchev took place. He worked with Buckminster Fuller on a geodesic dome for the 1967 World Expo in Montreal.
看到巴黎，那些伟大的咖啡馆和小酒馆，对我来说是一段完全美妙的经历。杰克·马西离开幽灵军队后，去了耶鲁大学艺术与建筑学院，靠的是《退伍军人权利法案》（G.I. Bill of Rights）。谢天谢地。从耶鲁毕业后，他设计了一些非常惊艳的东西。他设计了 1959 年莫斯科美国国家展览会上使用的厨房，尼克松和赫鲁晓夫著名的“厨房辩论”就是在那里发生的。他与巴克敏斯特·富勒（Buckminster Fuller）合作，为 1967 年蒙特利尔世界博览会设计了一个大地穹顶。
And Jack Macy wasn't the only artist in the ghost army to have a great career. Remember all those artists that were constantly sketching around Europe? Well, some of them became pretty famous after the war. Elzworth Kelly, the minimalist painter and sculptor, was in this unit. Arthur Singer, a wildlife artist who illustrated birds of North America and many other books Bill Blass, the fashion designer. Jack Macy and Bill Blass were good friends in the army and Jack likes to say that Bill Blass was the only soldier that read Vogue in his foxhole.
杰克·马西并不是幽灵军队中唯一拥有伟大职业生涯的艺术家。还记得那些一直在欧洲各地写生的艺术家吗？嗯，其中有一些人在战后变得相当有名。极简主义画家和雕塑家埃尔斯沃思·凯利（Elzworth Kelly）就曾在这支部队里。阿瑟·辛格（Arthur Singer），一位绘制了《北美鸟类》及许多其他书籍的野生动物艺术家。还有时尚设计师比尔·布拉斯（Bill Blass）。杰克·马西和比尔·布拉斯在军队里是好朋友，杰克喜欢说，比尔·布拉斯是唯一一个在散兵坑里读《Vogue》杂志的士兵。
Not only read Vogue in his foxhole, but he made sketches of fashion sketches wherever he went. He was forever working away, getting ready for the great moment when he was leaving the army. The government officially kept the Ghost Army a secret until the 1980s because they were hoping to be able to use some of the deception tactics in future conflicts. Some units were told not to talk about their experience ever to anyone, but apparently not everyone got the same directives on this. I was in company B and we were never told that we were not supposed to talk about it. So
不仅在散兵坑里读《Vogue》，而且无论走到哪里，他都在画时装草图。他一直在不停地工作，为离开军队的那伟大时刻做准备。政府官方一直将幽灵军队作为机密保守到上世纪 80 年代，因为他们希望能够在未来的冲突中继续使用某些欺骗战术。一些部队被告知永远不要向任何人谈论他们的经历，但显然并不是所有人都收到了相同的指示。“我在 B 连，我们从来没有被告知不准谈论此事。所以
I was blabbing about the ghost army the second I left it and everybody I had everybody reduced to gigantic laughs and amusement. I mean, the idea of a fake unit, pretty amusing thing. It is amusing, but beyond amusing, it's strange and amazing that they tried this and that they actually pulled it off. Not every operation was successful, but there's a number of operations where it's really clear that the Germans believed what they were
我一离开部队就在那儿喋喋不休地谈论幽灵军队，把所有人都逗得哈哈大笑、乐不可支。我的意思是，一支假军队的想法，确实是一件挺搞笑的事。”这确实很搞笑，但除了搞笑之外，他们尝试了这一点并且居然成功了，这既奇怪又惊人。并非每一次行动都成功了，但有许多行动非常清楚地表明，德国人相信了他们试图兜售的谎言，并且这确实对战争产生了影响。所以它确实帮助拯救了生命，确实帮助赢得了战争。
trying to sell them and that it had an effect on the war. So it did help to save lives, it did help to win the war. In the story of the Trojan horse after a grueling 10-year war, the Greeks win the war. In the story of the Trojan horse, after a grueling 10-year war, the Greeks pretend to give up and sail away, leaving behind a giant wooden horse which the Trojans drag back into their city as a victory trophy. At night, an elite force of Greek fighters which has been hiding inside the horse creeps out and is able to capture the city of Troy.
在特洛伊木马的故事中，经过长达十年艰苦卓绝的战争，希腊人赢得了战争。在特洛伊木马的故事中，经过长达十年艰苦卓绝的战争，希腊人假装放弃并扬帆起航，留下了一匹巨大的木马，特洛伊人将其拖回城内作为战利品。到了晚上，一直藏在马腹内的一支希腊精锐部队悄悄爬出来，成功攻占了特洛伊城。
Victory, my deception. That deception wouldn't have worked very well in World War II. When the Ghost Army's techniques probably wouldn't be very useful in today's conflicts. For obvious reasons, Rick couldn't get the army to tell him what kinds of deceptions they're doing these days. But you can be sure they're doing something, because, well, here, I'll let this guy say it. Deception of the enemy is, of course, as old as war itself. 99% of visible was produced this week by Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars.
胜利，属于我的欺骗。这种欺骗战术在第二次世界大战中可能不会那么管用。而幽灵军队的技术在今天的冲突中可能也没什么太大用处。出于显而易见的原因，里克无法让军方告诉他现在正在使用什么样的欺骗手段。但你可以确信他们确实在搞什么名堂，因为——好吧，我让这个人来说吧：“对敌人的欺骗，当然和战争本身一样古老。”本周的 99% Invisible 由凯蒂·明格尔制作，合作者包括山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马斯。
Special thanks to Jim Mingle, yes that's Katie's dad, for his help editing in fact checking this week. Rick Byer and co-author Elizabeth Sales' forthcoming book is called The Ghost Army of World War II. It's full of amazing images and so many more details about specific operations performed by The Ghost Army. It'll be out on April 28th. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interior's firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show in like the show on Facebook, we're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram,
特别感谢吉姆·明格尔（Jim Mingle，是的，那是凯蒂的父亲），感谢他协助本周的编辑和事实核查。里克·拜尔与合著者伊丽莎白·塞尔斯（Elizabeth Sales）即将出版的书名为《二战中的幽灵军队》（The Ghost Army of World War II）。书中充满了惊人的影像，以及更多关于幽灵军队执行的具体行动的细节。该书将于 4 月 28 日出版。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个节目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心建筑与室内设计公司 ArcSign 的办公室。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我们在 Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram
and Spotify, but the ghost army is haunting the pages of 99% of the book at 99pi.I. dot org. Radio TIPI. From P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和 Spotify 上也都有账号，不过“幽灵军队”正出没在 99pi.org 网站上《99%》一书的字里行间。Radio TIPI。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。